so the trolls contacted
everybody from my past life
to try and find holes in my story they
contacted my prosecutor
they contacted sammy the bull they've
contacted all of my ex-girlfriends
they've contacted everybody i've ever
written about i'll put a photo up about
or anybody they can find a photo of me
with
a social media they've contacted all of
my podcast guests
they've contact i mean this is just like
insanity
these people have these mentally ill
people have so much time on their hands
and it's insane so obviously they
contacted sammy the ball and said look
you know sean atwood he's made his
career
you know by talking [ __ ] about you are
you going to do something about it
so sami the ball got on
a camera i said this sean atwood if he's
you know if you [ __ ] up him hearing he's
a journalist and
he's a tv guy in england he's saying
he's built his career off of
my name um no i don't you know
i've never heard of the guy he's full of
[ __ ]
and if i'd bumped heads with him in
arizona
i'd be picking these bones out of my
teeth
that's what would have happened to him
so so anyway
i had to laugh and i'd like to set the
record straight right now
about this sammy the bull situation and
this is a clip that
i think will do really good for you
because this is so
viral and first thing i'd like to say is
i had so many aliases when i was running
my ecstasy
enterprise the prosecutor said she
couldn't even put them all on my grand
jury indictment
so if someone says to sammy the bull
who's the sean atwood guy
how the hell is he gonna know who shawn
atwood is because
i was just a shadowy figure running this
thing
without my real name ever been known to
anybody
so that's the first thing i'd like to
say second thing i'd like to say
is i love sammy the bulls youtube
channel
i've sent so many people over there he
is a master
storyteller reminds me of two tonys who
protected me in prison
there are so many people out there who
can't tell a story
and he is i'm riveted i've been watching
it and he's he's part of a
generation and there's not many of that
generation
still alive these iconic italian mafia
figures
so you know hats off to him for that
next thing i'd like to say is that
they they handcuffed wild man
to gerard gravano in towers jail
in 2002 2003 which is sammy the bull's
son
now on the streets you know
a lot of people have been saying they
were working for the bull
for sammy and i think i previously gave
you my story of
the guys i met in tucson who my uh
bisexual lesbian porn star wife was
dating one of their girlfriends
we met them i sat down with them and i
said it's the feds we need to worry
about
not each other you guys are lighting the
place up
uh you know when you need to chill and
there's plenty of demand for xc we could
co-exist
the piece didn't last long my top sales
guy skinner
one click from the gravano enterprise
enticed him to a nightclub in scottsdale
under the pretext of doing a deal with
him they took him into the men's room
and knocked his teeth out and took all
of his uh money
and all of his drugs and after that i
moved on to that property
sin vaccus catalina foothills tucson
arizona and the gated
gated guarded community so to of you
know as an
added layer of protection against
gravano's crew
at the same time had a female who had
penetrated into the gravano household
was attending barbecues over there was
giving me you know the layout
um we did some drive-bys on the street
and um
telling me about you know the associates
what they look like and who was over the
you know all these steroid head jock
guys
in the trainer and the track suits um
sports were
um at these barbecues with the gravanos
um
so that's where it was at on the streets
with the gravanos and people are saying
because sammy the boss is said i'm full
of [ __ ] he never knew me
i'm completely making all of this up but
if you go
to the police reports or if you go to
the phoenix
new times article it says that i was
sammy the bulls competitor in the xc
market and i had was established for so
long
that because i had done it for years
gravano just came in lit the place up
got arrested
i made him look like a flash in the pan
now that's coming from the cops
and the local media and people can you
know verify that
independently sammy has recently said
that he wasn't even running the xc
enterprise
so the question is were all these people
working for the gravano enterprise
just throwing his name out there saying
he was the boss
or you know were they actually working
for him and for whatever legal reasons
he's unable to say that back to towers
jail 2002 2003
so sammy the bulls crew they get
arrested a couple of years before my
crew
i'm like thanks cops you just wiped out
the competition
but all those resources that were on
gravano
were then put on to me um may 16
2002 that was when the swat team came so
they are running through the court
process a couple of years before
we are so when the guards knowingly
chained gerard gravano to wild man
they did that on purpose because they
wanted to see what would happen
they knew there was two crews that had
beef on the streets
now wildman looks at me like what should
i do
and i said because
you know we don't want to get any more
charges
these guys have probably got some good
legal information for us
they're ahead of the curve on this
they've been going through this for a
couple years
we should just sit down with him find
out what the tricks are the prosecutors
are playing on them
you know and how all this [ __ ] works and
that's what we did we sat there all
night with sammy the bull's son
um before we went to our court hearing
and we were fine with him
and i'm fine with him to this day and
the trolls have contacted him too
but he has acknowledged that he does
know who i am
and he was sentenced for as one of the
uh
dominant uh leaders of the ecstasy ring
so it's it's you know it's a hundred
percent that gerard gravano was near the
top
of whoever was running the extra ring
wherever the dad was
or whether he wasn't and prior to us
meeting gerard in the jail my
homie g-dog who
i told you last time introduced me to
his brothers in la may
where they had the rocket promote
grenade launcher on the tv
g-dog had i don't know if he'd been a
cell mate with gerard gravano
i'd gone to interview cell previously
and spoke to him when they first got
arrested this was
and said look you know don't [ __ ] with
english sean and peter because
we've got his back so that's how they
knew
who who was protecting us or at least
gerard did
and then you know down the road i've
kept in touch
with him um on email it's been it's been
years now since we had
an elastic communication but those guys
all went to hollywood
they're doing the straight and narrow
thing mob wives became that hit
tv show so you know kudos to karen
gravano
for pulling that off and i've read her
book and i i love her book
and i think what they're doing right now
is uh they're on the positive track
i offered to pay for sammy the ball
gravano
to fly to london so we could sit down
and have a
uh podcast recorded professionally
here in london that would have been a
huge
thing and people said well you only said
that because you know he can't travel
because he's got this criminal record
but we did the same thing with john
elite
map for your hitman for the gambinos you
know he admits to being involved in
multiple murders and he came to the uk
and me and wild man sat down with him
and that's one of the most
watched videos on the channel so that
offer is still open
uh if sammy the ball wants to come to
london we would love to sit down with
him
and get this filmed professionally and
if he's got any questions for me
i'd like to set that record straight
because i'm not full of [ __ ]
it's fully documented what we've done
and there's you know the
police recently i had to re
get my story re-verified through a tv
company i'm doing something with
it was already verified by national
geographic they had to see my paperwork
in the beginning for locked up abroad
and i'm looking at the uh the paperwork
recently it's you know it's right there
about
some of the witness statements the ten
witness statements that led to me
getting arrested were people who were
playing both sides
and oh they were just working for sammy
but then they told the cops they were
working for me and started to give them
all this information i'm hoping to
reduce their own sentences
all 57 of sammy the bulls co-defendants
agreed to cooperate
we had over 100 and only four agreed to
cooperate because we were tight
wow yeah that's [ __ ] insane that
would be a great conversation i feel
like between you and him
two big competing ecstasy enterprises
back in the back in the same era in
arizona that would be
has he has he answered you at all has
have you reached you've reached out to
him obviously has he responded yeah i
reached out to him through
a person who represents him rather than
doing any silly online stuff
and that person said presently he's not
going to do it
really yeah but he said he's focusing on
his channel and his channel is doing
great
and if you like those old-school mafia
stories
of you know dark tales of of blood and
guts
with gallows humor i urge people to go
over to sammy the balls channel
and check those stories out